DAY, VOTERS IN SEVEN STATES ARE
OLD CONGRESSIONAL SEAT.
BACK IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
THERE.
FOR GOVERNOR IN COLORADO.
CANDIDATES ARE SEEKING TO
REPLACE JOHN HICKENLOOPER.
IN MARYLAND, FORMER NAACP
PRESIDENT IS LOOKING TO TAKE ON
REPUBLICAN INCUMBENT LARRY
INFORMAL PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE IS
LOOKING AT A NEW PATH TO TRY TO
GET TO WASHINGTON.
CORRESPONDENT DAN SPRINGER IS IN
PROVO TONIGHT.
>> ON THE EVE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY IN UTAH, FORMER
MASSACHUSETTS GOVERNOR
MITT ROMNEY WAS STILL
BID FOR THE PRESIDENCY.
ROMNEY IS HOPING TO TAKE A BIG
STEP TODAY TOWARD ANOTHER JOB IN
WASHINGTON, THE U.S. SENATE AND
THE LATEST POLL SAYS HE IS A
VIRTUAL SHOO-IN WITH A 42-POINT
LEAD OVER HIS PRIMARY OPPONENT
MIKE KENNEDY.
IT'S GOT ROMNEY FINALLY AGREEING
TO DO NATIONAL INTERVIEWS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> IF I GET TO WASHINGTON I WILL
THINK ARE WRONG FOR THE COUNTRY
OR FOR THE STATE OF I WILL SPEAK
MY MIND ON ISSUES OF CONSCIENCE.
>> ROMNEY SAYS THERE WOULD BE NO
RETURN TO THE BOMB THROWING DAYS
OF 2016 WHEN HE WAS THE FACE OF
THE NEVER-TRUMP MOVEMENT.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS A PHONY, A
FRAUD.
>> HE WAS BEGGING FOR MY
ENDORSEMENT.
I COULD HAVE SAID DROP TO YOUR
KNEES, HE WOULD HAVE DROPPED TO
HIS KNEES.
>> AFTER TRUMP WAS ELECTED, BOTH
MEN STOOD DOWN AND ROMNEY EVEN
INTERVIEWED TO BE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
WHILE THE RELATIONSHIP THOUGHT,
SENATE BUT THEN IN FEBRUARY HE
SURPRISED HIM BY TWEETING HIS
ENDORSEMENT OF ROMNEY.
ROMNEY SAYS HE'S NOT READY TO
ENDORSE PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
TRUMP IS NO ROLE MODEL FOR
CHILDREN BUT INSISTS HE WILL NOT
TRY TO INFLUENCE THE WHITE HOUSE
TRY TO INFLUENCE THE WHITE HOUS
WHITE HOUSE.
>> TWO SEPARATE BRANCHES, MY JOB
IS TO TRY TO GET THINGS THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH THAT ARE
RIGHT FOR THE COUNTRY.
I'M NOT GOING TO TRY AND MANAGE
THE WHITE HOUSE OR HOW THE
PRESIDENT INTERACTS WITH OTHERS.
THAT'S UP TO HIM AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION AND HIS TEAM.
>> IF MITT ROMNEY WINS TONIGHT
AS IT IS WIDELY EXPECTED IT HE
WILL TAKE ON DEMOCRAT JENNY
WILSON WHO IS A CURRENT CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER IN SALT LAKE CITY
AND ALSO THE DAUGHTER OF A LONG
TIME MAYOR THERE.
JUST TO SHOW YOU THE CHALLENGE
THAT LIES AHEAD FOR HER.
WHEN ROMNEY RAN FOR PRESIDENT HE
WON UTAH.